all right so I'm walking into this
I guess it's an interview I don't know
but we're going to go talk to China the
country what's up man
cool man cool it's ready to go yeah yeah
yeah let's drop some names did what you
got well William tell me what you want
to talk about what are we gonna do dude
I'm just I feel like I'm inside a Nick
Cage over here just make sure you grab a
Sean Penn a piece of paper all right
yeah dude oh dear my legs are so tired
all this Christian for walking man those
people were Leon DeGeneres had hi man
did you heart hair come Kevin Bacon I
mean the guy asked me if I was done
eating I said I was done so Washington
man feels really good should be here or
even the mudguard spot I can't even
think one oh good we're out all right
all right what's up man Stevo not a nice
tomato man so what are you doing then
Wow Emily team hello James everybody
care if I'm if I'm videoing all right
yeah look at this room's window man you
can see for miles dings got a nice kurt
angle of the hollywood sign over there
zoom in ah yeah what are you doing dude
I'm just thinking about you know look at
me if I really enjoy this view and I
said and I love it oh yeah why Jimmy
Lovitz people I don't know how long I've
known Scott over here man we just
celebrated our second Rihanna ver sory
we're all so high I feel like Marty
McFly in this is only the Ethan Hawke's
just chilling around hi whatever the
[ __ ] I'm doing here man but
Hey hello hello
say can you say some cool stuff in
Chinese I can say some calls up in
Chinese um how about um I'm here with
the man who stables his ball sack uh
what's a net again steve-o catch on
schambach how this out TV yo me good
Beauty peanuts wait yeah whoo super cool
all right I mean I knew I was gonna have
a good time today
okay good not just with one house but
with three that's right all right what's
your name my name is Emily Sara I'll
introduce myself again
I ride oh that's a how is she called
that tinkin alum Indian Ocean Ensenada
tabular to show she went full on the
waist you know what we should do much
wonder you know why she wants vocation
at Padua eating
do you go how should I approach awaited
the dog vomit in doubt in case you
change the jooheon chico das debo
yeah well coca cuz I just smoked a lot
of Chinese and I just welcomed you to
our studio well I appreciate that
so this is steve-o's name in Chinese
goes like this
okay I like it okay and it's shitty food
oh [ __ ] deep blue Oh shitty food offices
all right you know I wish I was running
this during the interview because I was
[ __ ] being nuts and and I've had so
much fun but you know my brother how do
I tell people how to watch it Oh
shows on internet I know do they have to
type in [ __ ] that looks like that and
we're gonna watch that interview
all right cool
okay thank you guys so much what are you
kidding me all right live from Hollywood
it's steve-o thank you for watching fans
tang on Tessa yeah yeah whoo [ __ ]
nailed it what bye bye guys